Про роботу Верховної Ради дев'ятого скликання
сьогодні говоримо з головою парламенту Дмитром Разумковим.
Дмитре Олександровичу, буквально днями буде рік,
як працює Рада монобільшості. Чи задоволені Ви своєю роботою за цей рік?
Я думаю, треба це не нас питати.
Треба запитувати у людей,
і саме вони будуть давати свою оцінку і нашій роботі, і роботі влади в цілому.
Але я, мабуть, буду нечесним, якщо скажу, що
все що ми робили мені подобалося або ми не робили помилок. Це буде неправда.
Ми багато зробили правильних речей.
Ми багато чого ще не встигли зробити.
Я думаю, що тут важливо визнавати те, що ти не можеш бути постійно правий.
Є проблеми, є помилки, є і досягнення. Це теж правда.
І треба рухатися саме в такій парадигмі.
Свою роботу Верховна Рада ІХ скликання розпочала з турборежиму.
Це вже таке трохи брендове ваше слово.
Закони приймалися дуже швидко, злагоджено, монобільшість голосувала.
Але Комітет виборців порахував, що принаймні кількісно ви були менш продуктивними,
ніж ваші колеги з VІІІ скликання за перші півроку.
На Ваш погляд, такий турборежим він був виправданий?
І які рішення все-таки не вдалося прийняти.
Я думаю, що роботу парламенту ІХ скликання можна
по багатьом аспектам вважати ефективною, і в тому числі
по підтримці тих чи інших законопроектів в залі.
Я розумію, що випадок з монобільшістю –
це перший випадок в історії українського парламентаризму, але також,
якщо ми подивимось на рівень підтримки законів,
то якщо я не помиляюся, за перший рік роботи Верховної Ради України
ми з результатом понад 300 голосів прийняли понад 80 законів.
За минулу каденцію їх було 26.
І я думаю, що це теж є показник злагодженої роботи парламенту.
Попри ці 150 законопроектів, проголосованих монобільшістю,
були ті, які ні монобільшість не підтримала,
ні навіть просто більшості не знайшлося, наприклад програм дій уряду,
за яку віддали голоси 207 депутатів.
Чи говорить це про те, що монобільшість стає крихка і десь в чомусь ситуативна?
Ні, я думаю, що про це мова зараз не йде.
Я багато інших законопроектів можу навести,
за які не голосувала монобільшість і не голосував зал.
І я вважаю, що це навпаки
демонструє розуміння процесів в парламенті.
І відповідальність, яка лежить на народних депутатах
за прийняття того чи іншого рішення.
Комітет виборців України оприлюднив аналіз,
в якому йдеться про те, що Верховна Рада підтримала
лише 4% відсотки урядових ініціатив законодавчих.
Чи не йдеться про протиріччя між гілками влади
і чим воно може бути небезпечне, якщо так?
Ні, на щастя, не йдеться.
Якщо ми говоримо про ті 4%, які ви щойно згадали,
то я думаю, що мова йде про ті, що були розглянуті Верховною Радою,
а не були розглянуті і відхилені.
Мається на увазі трохи інше.
Насправді багато ініціатив,
вони є спільними з представниками Кабінету міністрів, з профільними міністерствами.
Але вони вносяться народними депутатами України.
Це значно прискорює процес розгляду
і можливо прийняття їх у Верховній Раді України.
Тобто мова про якийсь конфлікт в цьому плані не йде.
Я думаю, що ви не станете спростовувати той факт, що всередині самої фракції
є поділ на такі групи, підгрупи із впливом олігархів.
І час від часу ці групи влаштовують саботаж, як було з «антиколомойським» законом,
коли було внесено 16 тисяч правок,
і тоді президент особисто звертався до депутатів, закликаючи їх проголосувати.
На Вашу думку, чи не є таке блокування свідченням того,
що немає єдності цієї монобільшості через вплив олігархів?
І чи маєте Ви особисто вплив на всі ці групи депутатів?
Ні, я свідомий того, що вони можуть орієнтуватися
на ситуацію на ринку і на політичному ринку.
Але навішувати ярлики, що ця людина
на 100% залежить від представника великого бізнесу,
я думаю, що все-таки не варто і не зовсім коректно.
Щодо 16 тисяч правок – да, я вважаю, що це не спроба покращити закон,
а спроба загальмувати його.
Ми бачили схожу ситуацію з ринком землі.
Я 100% є противником такої технології.
Вона нова, але вона
дуже небезпечна для парламентаризму і для Верховної Ради України.
Тому що за такими намірами ми можемо
фактично заблокувати роботу парламенту. А це може призвести
до катастрофічних наслідків, особливо в умовах,
що держава знаходиться у війні, що сьогодні інша війна з коронавірусом
і багато інших викликів, які сьогодні також стоять перед нашою державою.
З партією «Слуга народу» до парламенту прийшли нові обличчя.
Ви були причетні до формування цього списку.
Це люди, які не мали жодного політичного досвіду, управлінського досвіду.
Чи спостерігаєте Ви певний прогрес і чи задоволені Ви
новими обличчями в ролі депутатів за цей рік?
Вони не були народними депутатами України до цього.
Це правда. Але частина з них була депутатами місцевих рад.
Частина з них була міськими головами.
І багато інших прикладів успішності в бізнесі й інших напрямках.
Да, були ті, які прийшли з абсолютно інших сфер.
І деякий досвід отримували вже в самій Верховній Раді.
Але я бачу багато тих людей, які змінилися в кращу сторону.
Є мабуть й ті, які змінилися в не кращу сторону.
Це теж правда і це теж реалії нашого з вами життя.
Навіть не політики, а саме життя.
Колеги-журналісти підмітили, що в перші місяці роботи Верховної Ради
Вам доводилося скеровувати недосвідчених депутатів,
наприклад коли Ви ставили питання на голосування,
ви ніби натякали їм і казали, що «колеги підтримуємо»,
це ніби означало, що вони мають натиснути кнопку «за».
Або «колеги, голосуємо», це означало проти.
Що це було?
Я теж народний депутат і маю право на свою позицію.
Я теж її озвучую. Я можу сказати і прошу голосувати, і прошу підтримати
і прошу визначатися, по-різному.
Але навіть якщо ви подивитеся на голосування,
то дуже часто моя позиція не завжди співпадає з позицією народних депутатів.
Хоча думаю, по більшості кількості питань, думаю за 90% вона схожа.
Тобто Ви таким чином таки натякали їм,
а вони в 90% випадків прислухалися до спікера Разумкова?
Ні, я думаю, що навіть більше. Десь 95% чи навіть більше.
Але це не демонстрація натякання,
а це саме демонстрація спільного бачення тих чи інших процесів.
Депутати нинішнього складу Верховної Ради ще прославилися багатьма скандалами,
наприклад переписка в Раді Богдана Яременка,
сексистський діалог Олександра Корнієнка з Давидом Арахамією,
потім ще була робота ресторану Тищенка під час карантину і ще багато інших.
Чи на Вашу думку, оці скандали
і такі вчинки депутатів не дискредитували парламент загалом?
Я не буду зараз виступати адвокатом своїх колег.
Багато хто з них визнав свою провину і помилку і вибачався,
хтось, на жаль, ні, але я думаю, що кожен повинен відповідати в першу чергу за себе.
Додає це парламенту? Ні, це погано.
Дискредитує це парламент? Так, дискредитує.
Мені б хотілося, як керівнику парламенту, щоб таких скандалів не було.
Але сподіваюся, що не буде і таких скандалів, і хочу вірити,
що в цьому парламенті не будуть з’являтися і корупційні скандали.
Ви були в команді Володимира Зеленського ще до того,
як він оголосив свій намір балотуватися в президенти,
однак з деяких джерел до ЗМІ потрапила інформація,
що нинішній очільник Офісу президента Андрій Єрмак
не задоволений Вашою надмірною самостійністю, повагою до Вас з боку колег
і вивчає можливості для Вашої відставки.
Чи відомо Вам про це і які наразі у вас стосунки з паном Єрмаком?
Нормальні в мене стосунки з Андрієм Борисовичем.
Ми працюємо достатньо ефективно,
тому нічого додати з цього приводу не можу.
Я сподіваюся, що всі розуміють, що нормальна робота
вона в першу чергу потрібна ні мені або комусь іншому.
Вона потрібна державі. Але кожен приймає рішення самостійно.
Володимир Зеленський вже не виключає свого походу на другий термін.
А Ви от їздите регіонами, спілкуєтеся з різними групами людей,
і це виглядає теж, як такий натяк на президентські амбіції.
Можливо тому Єрмак незадоволений?
Розкажіть про свої далекоглядні, більш стратегічні плани.
Тут немає далекоглядних планів. Ми можемо підняти те, що я казав під час виборчої кампанії.
Я щиро в це вірив, вірю і буду вірити, в те, що будь-який чиновник,
незалежно від того голова це Верховної Ради,
народний депутат чи міністр, він повинен спілкуватися з людьми.
Я не зовсім розумію, коли я там приїжджаю в той чи інший регіон,
а мені кажуть «у нас голова Верховної Ради не приїжджав 10 років, 14 років».
Це не нормально. Тому що ми люди, яких обирають громадяни нашої держави.
І сидіти лише під куполом чи лише в кабінетах – це втрати зв'язок з тими людьми,
які за тебе віддали свої голоси і які тобі довірили цю владу.
Свої посади за час президентства Володимира Зеленського втратила одразу декілька осіб,
які дуже тісно працювали з Вами в його передвиборчому штабі.
Це Олександр Данилюк, Андрій Богдан і Руслан Рябошапка.
Всі вони пішли не найкращим чином. Чи змінилися ваші стосунки з президентом
за цей час і як змінився сам Володимир Зеленський?
Посади також накладають свій відбиток на людину, відповідальність накладає
на сприйняття тих чи інших процесів, тому всі ми змінюємося.
Головне, щоб змінювалися на краще.
Якщо ми говоримо про робочі аспекти, мені здається, що достатньо конструктивно .
йде робота  парламенту й президента
Ви це теж бачите. І підтримка президентських законопроектів
дуже часто набирає за 300 голосів.
Я думаю, що достатньо консолідовано ми працюємо в трикутнику
Верховна Рада-Президент Україні-Кабінет міністрів України.
Поговорімо про ті законопроекти, які можуть бути проголосовані парламентом під час 4 сесії,
зокрема закон про мову, ініційований Максимом Бужанським.
Він став причиною протестів під Верховною Радою.
Напевно вже цього навчального року учні 5-11 класів, які вчилися до цього російською,
таки будуть навчатися українською, тому що не буде вже він ймовірно проголосований.
Але Ви неодноразово говорили про те, що закон про мову потрібно змінювати.
Про які зміни йдеться?
Що це має бути? Квоти на телебаченні, мова навчання, що ще, на Вашу думку?
Багато аспектів, які там відображені були, м’яко кажучи, розкритиковані і Венеційською комісією,
Організацією Об’єднаних Націй.
Я вважаю, що закони пов’язані з гуманітарною сферою вони повинні влаштовувати
чи намагатися влаштувати всіх громадян України.
Якщо ми говоримо про повернення тимчасово окупованих територій,
то ми також повинні створювати умови,
які будуть додавати українській позиції і в Донецьку, і в Луганську, в Севастополі і в Сімферополі.
Мова як одна з умов цього повернення може бути?
Ну дивіться, якщо ми говоримо про мову, то питання мови піднімають впершу чергу ви,
журналісти, піднімають політики.
Ми якщо згадаємо виборчу кампанію, ми не піднімали питання мови.
Ми не збирали майдани за або проти. Тому що треба, що одне одного чули,
а іноді наші опоненти так не вважають  і якщо ми будемо думати,
що лише наша думка єдино правильна,
то це призводить до того, що частина суспільства пересає тебе чути.
Дмитре Олександровичу, які законопроекти будуть найпріоритетнішими
для наступної сесії Верховної Ради?
З урахуванням того, що сьогодні, м’яко кажучи, непроста ситуація в Україні і в світі,
я думаю, що основним із пріоритетних законопроектів наступної сесії є бюджет.
Тому саме бюджет – це той законопроект, який буде на наступній сесії
одним з ключових, оскільки саме по цьому бюджету буде жити держава в наступному році.
Ви згадали про бюджет, але ми зараз стоїмо напевно на порозі,
як кажуть інфекціоністи й експерти, другої хвилі пандемії коронавірусу.
Чи є у Верховній Раді зареєстровані якісь законопроекти, щоб цю ситуацію виправити,
якщо таки друга хвиля буде?
Ми не можемо законом заборонити COVID, на жаль.
Якщо б це було можливо, ми б вже прийняли цей законопроект.
Те, що залежало від Верховної Ради, ми я думаю, в повному об’ємі зробили.
Ми створили ковідівський фонд, гроші туди були рішенням Верховної Ради переведені, ви пам’ятаєте.
Сьогодні я сподіваюся, що все ж таки ми зможемо більш-менш спокійно пройти цей етап.
Якщо треба буде втручання Верховної Ради, народні депутати будуть завжди до цього готові.
Останні соціологічні опитування показують, що якби вибори до парламенту відбулися зараз,
то за «Слугу народу» проголосувало б близько 28% виборців серед тих, хто вже визначився.
Тобто можна припустити, що рейтинг партії впав десь на третину за рік.
Як би Ви це прокоментували? З чим це може бути пов’язано?
Це, на жаль, реалії, з якими буде зіштовхуватися не лише «Слуга народу»,
а й в принципі будь-яка влада. Тішить мене це?
Ні, це погано, але якщо ми подивимося по динаміці, вона також не така  погана,
як іноді її малюють. А місцеві вибори будуть трохи іншими,
тому що багато залежить від того, хто буде йти на місцях від тієї чи іншої політичної сили.
Володимир Зеленський казав, що йому на посаді президента не вистачає часу на сон,
не вистачає часу на дітей. Чим Вам довелося пожертвувати для того,
щоб обійняти одну з ключових державних посад?
Не знаю. Я не думаю, що треба чимось жертвувати. Багато працювати.
Я й раніше багато працював, з 7.30 на роботі. І до цього, на жаль, сім'я і родина звикли.
Да, я іноді менше бачу дітей, да я іноді менше можу приділити їм часу.
Мабуть, це найбільше, чим довелося пожертвувати. А всім іншим?
Я сподіваюся залишатися такою людиною, як я був і до того, як потрапив до цього кабінету.
І я думаю, що будь-який політик повинен це пам’ятати і розуміти,
що в цьому світі немає нічого вічного.
Сьогодні ти можеш бути головою Верховної Ради, а завтра ні.
Але важливо, щоб ти залишався людиною, тим Дмитром Разумковим, який був
і до того, як стати головою Верховної Ради і буде таким самим,
коли можливо перестане їм бути.